THIS CONVENES THE. RULES
COMMITTEE MEETING FOR THURSDAY
MARCH FIRST TWENTY EIGHTEEN.
THE RULES BECAUSE HEREBY CALLED
ORDER. PLEASE BE ADVISED ON
AUDIO AND VIDEO RECORDINGS BEING
MADE OF TODAY'S PROCEEDINGS AS
ALSO BEING TELEVISED. BENEFACTOR
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL COOLLY HERE
CUNNINGHAM ALLAN. BRO CORREO
PRESENT. SERVANDO HERE. FREEDMAN
GRACE CENTER AS AREA SOLACE.
WALTER AND.
HAVE A PLAN. WE HAVE A QUORUM
AND WE HAVE A CONSENT AGENDA. IS
OUR MOTION ON THE CONSENT AGENDA
SECOND BY MISTER GRAY'S SECOND
BY MISTER RANTERS. OF MATTER
SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
COOLLY I COOLLY I CUNNINGHAM
ALLAN BRO. CORREO.
CORREO ICE AROUND TEN TIMES
AROUND AS I'VE READ. GRAYSON.
GRAYSON INEZ ERAN SOLACE. SOLACE
I WON'T TURN ON FALTERED I.
OKAY A SOCIALIST PAST AND THIS
WILL TO TURN. OVER